j'étais venu surtout découvrir des
mangas parce que j'en connais pas
beaucoup captain tsubasa bord auto ou
encore my hero academia des centaines de
personnes toutes générations confondues
se sont rassemblés le 15 juin dernier à
poissy pour célébrer la culture manga
les enfants sont très contents les
adolescents bien sûr sont là pour en
apprendre plus discutés avoir des
techniques on sent que ça l'est ça les
intéresse est évidemment il ya aussi des
adultes qui sont passés quand même la
france on a beaucoup de d'amateurs de
bande dessinée il ya aussi beaucoup
d'adultes qui sont très intéressés je
connais pas beaucoup de mangas du coup
bas cet endroit ça me permet aussi d'en
découvrir et puis bah du coup j'ai
demandé à un mangaka je me destine à
baa1 descendre un personnage de manga
que ma meilleure amie aime beaucoup et
en fait ça m'a impressionné le mouvement
qu'il a avec son poignet tout ça au
programme expositions ateliers et
échanges comme guest star ahmed and co
fondateur de la maison d'édition ki moon
aujourd'hui c'était un c'était un public
de néophytes et c'est souvent les
publics les plus importants parce qu'on
l'a extrême un nombre extrêmement
important de questions qui vont de la
question très naïve à la question
surprenamment renseigner donc non non
c'est toujours très enthousiasmante moi
j'ai toujours considéré qu'il avait pas
de réfractaires au manga et que même
même chez ceux qui sont persuadés que
c'est pas pour eux il ya toujours un
manga ou un type de manga susceptibles
de les aider de les séduire objectif de
l'événement convertir deux futurs
lecteurs et montrer que tout le monde
peut trouver le style de manga qui lui
correspond le mieux il a eu besoin de
personne il a été méprisé pendant très
longtemps par les élites qui considérait
que c'était c'était du dessin de bas de
gamme qu'on voyait à la télévision avec
des scènes de violence il s'est
démocratisé tout seul s'est imposé tout
seul en france désormais la france est
le 2ème la deuxième patrie du manga au
monde après le japon et donc ça marche
tout seul c'est aujourd'hui une bd sur
deux vendu en france est un manga et
pour ceux qui ont manqué cette première
édition pas de panique la fête du manga
d'aisé been compte bien revenir pour un
deuxième tome